I made Ted lasso's biscuits to melt the
hearts of my enemies
though these appear to be just a simple
shortbread in the show the meaning of
these little pink boxes of biscuits goes
much deeper for Ted these cookies are a
gesture of unsolicited kindness and
compassion even when the recipient does
not deserve it I love this show so much
because it doesn't dismiss Ted's endless
optimism as ignorance and pretend like
pessimism is the only way to
realistically go through life it
demonstrates that the belief that good
things are coming is an intentional
strategy and that despite our many
differences like whether you prefer
coffee or tea say soccer versus football
or leave a peanut butter jar open on
your counter or not there is always room
for us to find common ground so that's
why